in the forecast fragment class we add
the callback interface that was provided
in the gist then in the oncreate view
method we modify the list item click
behavior when an item is clicked instead
of always launching a new intent to the
detail activity we want to notify the
callback instead we call get activity
and then cast it to a callback object
then we can call on item selected on it
we pass the URI that represents the
selected location and date then in the
main activity we implement the callback
interface in the on item selected method
we fork the behavior based on the m2
pain variable that we defined earlier if
we're in to pain mode then we create a
detail fragment and put the URI inside
the arguments bundle then we replace the
existing detail fragment in the weather
detail container using the detail
fragment tag in one pane mode we create
a new intent to launch the detail
activity and we set the data URI in the
detail activity we modify the oncreate
method to read the data URI from the
incoming intent we take the URI and set
it as the arguments in the new detail
fragment then we dynamically add this
fragment to this container in the detail
fragment we modify the oncreate view
method to read the arguments that the
fragment was initialized with we read
the data URI and store that in the
member variable M URI in the oncreate
loader method we remove some code that
relied on the incoming intent and
switched it to use mu RI instead whether
this detail fragment is in the main
activity or the detail activity it
should have em your eye set then we're
going to use mu RI to query the content
provider for the data to display in this
detail fragment when you try it out on
the tablet there is one bug related to
navigation that we should fix say we
select tomorrow state if you navigate to
the settings activity and then hit the
UP button the detail fragment is blank
that's because a brand new instance of
main activity got launched and for a
brand new instance nothing is selected
yet to fix this when the settings
activity up button is pressed we want to
navigate to the previous running
instance of the main activity where the
tomorrow item is
did and not create a new instance of
main activity in the settings activity
override this method which the system
will call in order to get the parent
activity intent for the UP button
behavior get the parent activity intent
from the superclass this should create a
new intent to main activity then add the
intent flag called flag activity clear
top this flag indicates that we should
check if the main activity is already
running in our task and to use that one
instead of creating a new main activity
instance also this method didn't exist
prior to jelly bean so we need to add
this at target API annotation if you
check the documentation for the activity
class the gab parent activity and tent
method was only added in API level 16
and you can check that version 16 maps
to jelly bean